Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je joue régulièrement avec mon fils
de 4 ans à son jeu préféré, les Lego.
Il adore construire, jouer
et puis détruire tout ce qu’il a fait.
Mais il y a une chose qu’il n’aime pas
particulièrement, c’est ranger.
Et si vous avez déjà marché
pieds nus sur une pièce de Lego,
vous savez que c’est important
de les ranger après avoir joué.
Cet été, j’ai trouvé la parade.
Je lui ai lancé un défi :
dix minutes pour construire
la voiture la plus stylée.
Celui de nous deux qui perd
range les Lego.
On était ultra motivés.
Je lance le chrono et de suite,
j’imagine une voiture de sport,
des pièces transparentes
pour voir le moteur,
un aileron à l’arrière,
et sur le côté des portes papillon.
Mais au bout des dix minutes,
je n’avais pas du tout fini ma voiture.
Alors j’ai regardé mon fils.
Et j’étais un peu rassuré,
lui non plus n’avait pas fini.
Enfin,
c’est ce que je croyais.
Il avait déjà réalisé deux bolides,
dont un qui pouvait voler.
Et il en était à sa troisième voiture.
Il m’a non seulement battu,
mais il m’a littéralement pulvérisé.
Cette scène m’a marqué.
Pourquoi ?
Déjà parce que j’ai perdu -
je n’aime pas perdre -
mais surtout
parce que j’ai réalisé que nous avions
deux approches complètement différentes
d'aborder ce défi.
La mienne
consiste en un plan parfait,
mais n’aboutit à rien de concret.
Je n'ai pas fini.
La sienne peut être imparfaite,
mais beaucoup plus créative et surtout,
à la fin, il les avait, ses deux bolides.
Ces deux approches,
c’est en fait deux mondes
complètement différents :
celui de la réflexion
et celui de l’action.
Et j’ai compris que la combinaison
de ces deux mondes
offre un potentiel de dingue.
Ça donne la capacité d’innover,
ça offre la possibilité
de changer les choses,
la faculté de changer le monde.
Je m’appelle Denis Gahlia Garcia
et je suis depuis toujours
fasciné par l’innovation.
Cette fascination m'a d'abord amené
à faire des études d'ingénieur.
J'ai appris à construire,
à concevoir une idée.
Et puis,
je suis devenu ingénieur conseil
en innovation.
J’ai eu la chance pendant dix ans
d’accompagner des centaines
de projets divers et variés.
Des projets d’innovation de produits,
de procédés, de services,
des innovations technologiques,
non technologiques,
émanant de laboratoires, de start-ups
ou de grands groupes.
Aujourd’hui,
je vais vous parler d’innovation,
mais je vais vous dire pourquoi,
si, mon fils et moi, on fait équipe,
on peut faire de grandes choses,
et surtout,
je vais vous montrer comment
si on fait équipe tous ensemble,
on peut relever des défis colossaux,
on peut relever les plus grands
challenges de l’humanité,
tels que le réchauffement climatique.
Avant de commencer,
laissez-moi vous dire ce que
je mets derrière ce mot « innovation ».
L’innovation,
c’est l’action d’apporter une nouveauté -
un nouveau modèle,
une nouvelle façon de penser.
Ça intègre une notion de changement.
Et cette notion est essentielle.
Elle permet notamment de distinguer
l'innovation du progrès.
Le progrès, c'est une amélioration,
mais dans la même direction.
Concrètement, ce n'est pas en améliorant
la bougie qu'on a inventé l'ampoule.
L’amélioration de la bougie, on est sur
le progrès, l’ampoule sur l’innovation.
Laissez-moi aussi
vous partager une erreur,
l’erreur la plus fréquente que j’ai
vue dans les projets d’innovation,
une erreur que
j’ai moi-même faite au début.
Cette erreur, c’est de penser
que l’innovation
repose sur avoir la bonne idée.
Une idée seule ne vaut rien.
Une idée ne change rien.
Moi, des idées, j'en ai plein.
Et elles sont excellentes en plus.
Mais concrètement, avec ces idées, pour
l’instant, qu’est-ce que j’ai changé ?
Que dalle !
Ce qui est rigolo avec les idées,
c’est qu’on a tendance
à vouloir les garder pour soi.
On ne veut pas les partager
de peur qu’on nous les vole.
C'est bien la preuve qu'on imagine
qu'elles ont de la valeur.
Mais ce qui compte,
c’est la concrétisation de ces idées,
c’est l’exécution, la capacité
de les mettre en œuvre efficacement.
Regardez l'exemple avec mon fils.
Ses bolides sont certes imparfaits,
et il a perdu rapidement une roue ou deux,
mais il a pu jouer avec.
Moi, mon bolide, ma voiture de course,
sont toujours uniquement dans ma tête.
Alors, penser qu’innover,
c’est avoir la bonne idée,
c’est passer à côté de l’essentiel.
Il existe un tas de facteurs
qui influencent la réussite
ou non d’une innovation.
Il y a les performances
techniques du produit,
mais il va y avoir aussi la communication,
le marketing associé,
le design, les achats,
la façon de produire,
le modèle économique même.
D’ailleurs, on voit bien qu’il y a
tous ces facteurs qui influencent,
et du coup, ce ne sont pas forcément
les meilleures idées qui réussissent.
Laissez-moi prendre un exemple.
La vis cruciforme.
Vous savez, celle en forme de croix.
C’est la vis la plus répandue au monde.
Vous avez forcément monté une table,
un meuble ou un lit avec cette vis.
Si elle est si répandue,
c’est que c’est forcément la meilleure.
Eh bien, en tant qu'ingénieur,
je peux vous dire que non.
Mécaniquement, il existe
des tas d’autres vis bien meilleures,
et notamment une vis
avec une empreinte de tête carrée.
Les efforts sont bien plus faibles
pour la visser
et elle s’use beaucoup moins vite.
Mais alors, pourquoi c’est
cette vis cruciforme qu’on a partout ?
Eh bien, c'est une question d'exécution.
Ces deux innovations, finalement,
ont été inventées en même temps.
Deux inventeurs, deux brevets.
La vis à tête carrée, la vis cruciforme.
La différence ?
L’innovateur de la vis cruciforme
a collaboré avec un homme d’affaires.
Ce dernier a travaillé
sur la communication,
sur les outils de production
et a noué des partenariats
avec l’industrie automobile,
alors en plein boom.
Vous allez me dire :
« Concrètement tant que j’arrive à visser
ma chaise, mon meuble ou ma table,
peu importe la forme de la vis. »
Et vous avez bien raison.
Mais il y a des thématiques sur
lesquelles la réussite d’une innovation
peut tout simplement être vitale.
C’est le cas dans le domaine médical,
dans le domaine de l’écologie,
et plus particulièrement dans le cas
du réchauffement climatique.
J’ai réalisé ça il y a quatre ans,
quand j’ai pris conscience et j’ai compris
l’ampleur de la crise climatique
dans laquelle nous sommes.
Comme beaucoup, je pensais
qu'on avait le temps.
Je pensais qu’un réchauffement
planétaire de quelques degrés,
c’était l’histoire d’un pull en moins.
Je ne savais pas que
le changement climatique,
c’est l’augmentation
en nombre et en intensité
de phénomènes tels que les sécheresses,
les inondations, les canicules,
les feux, les tempêtes.
Je ne savais pas que
le changement climatique
était un voyage en aller simple,
quelque chose où on ne peut pas
revenir en arrière.
Le CO2 est un gaz stable.
Une fois qu’il est dans l’atmosphère,
il y est pour des siècles.
Il n'est pas facile de l'enlever.
Et je ne savais pas
que le changement climatique
allait tout simplement
devenir inarrêtable.
A partir d’un certain seuil
de réchauffement,
il existe des phénomènes d’emballement
et le réchauffement
s’auto-alimente tout seul.
Clairement,
on est dans une situation
plutôt dramatique.
Mais on a de la chance.
Oui, on a de la chance, car on sait
exactement ce qu'il se passe.
On a de la chance, car on sait aussi
exactement ce qu'il faut faire.
Il faut diviser les émissions globales de
gaz à effet de serre par deux d’ici 2030
et atteindre la neutralité
carbone d'ici 2050.
La sobriété,
le fait de consommer moins, de consommer
plus intelligemment sera un axe essentiel,
mais, je vous le dis, malheureusement
largement insuffisant.
Le défi devant nous est immense,
on a besoin de repenser en profondeur
notre économie,
de repenser en profondeur nos industries,
nos transports, nos infrastructures,
notre agriculture.
Heureusement,
la bonne nouvelle,
c’est qu’il existe un tas
de solutions pour cela.
La moins bonne,
c’est que, sans capacité d’exécution,
ces solutions-là risquent
de ne jamais voir le jour.
Alors, je vous propose une expérience.
Et si ensemble, on formait une équipe,
et on avait le pouvoir de changer
les choses et d’éviter ce problème ?
Imaginez.
Imaginez qu’au-delà des actions
individuelles, on se regroupe
et on crée ensemble une entreprise, une
entreprise qui nous appartiendrait à tous.
Imaginez que cette entreprise
ait une mission :
la mission de décarboner le monde.
Et uniquement cette mission.
On ne s’enrichirait pas
avec cette entreprise.
Imaginez maintenant que, tous ensemble,
on utilise l’intelligence collective pour
trouver les solutions les plus pertinentes
pour réduire les gaz à effet de serre.
Et l’intelligence collective, ce n’est pas
une simple notion marketing,
c'est un vrai fait scientifique.
Les études et expérimentations sur
le sujet sont tout simplement bluffantes.
Je ne sais pas si vous savez,
mais en 1999, par exemple,
un collectif de 50 000 joueurs
d’échecs amateurs
a mis à mal et a challengé le plus grand
champion du monde de la discipline,
le numéro un mondial, le Russe Kasparov.
Ils ont même réalisé un coup qui est
rentré dans les annales des échecs.
Bluffant, non ?
Un collectif d'amateurs peut
challenger un expert.
Et même aller au-delà.
Imaginez maintenant que ces solutions
que l’on a trouvées,
on leur apporte
cette capacité d’exécution.
On leur donne de l’argent,
on leur donne un profil complémentaire
qui vient compléter l’équipe scientifique,
un profil qui vient du monde de l’action,
un entrepreneur.
Et ensemble, ils peuvent
développer l’innovation.
Et enfin, imaginez que
ces solutions développées,
on les diffuse massivement
partout dans le monde
en les partageant gratuitement.
On a tous un exemple en tête
que l’on connaît,
qui illustre que le partage est
la méthode la plus efficace
pour diffuser rapidement une solution
à travers le monde.
Les conférences TED.
Clairement, TED est aujourd’hui
la référence en termes de conférences,
avec des milliards de vues
partout dans le monde.
Comment ils en sont arrivés là ?
Une des clés a été
de passer d’un modèle fermé
de conférences payantes
uniquement sur invitation
à un modèle en ligne gratuit
et ouvert à tous.
Alors imaginez tout ça.
Ça ressemble à une belle idée, non ?
Une bonne idée
qui vaut que dalle
sans exécution.
Eh bien, c'est ce que nous avons fait,
cette exécution, justement.
Il y a deux ans,
nous avons lancé un projet un peu fou,
un projet appelé « Time for the Planet ».
Au début, nous sommes six co-fondateurs,
six profils complémentaires,
avec une sacrée capacité d’action.
Je vous mets au défi -
je vous déconseille plutôt -
de venir nous défier aux Lego.
Aujourd’hui, nous sommes
plus de 30 000 dans cette entreprise,
répartis dans plus de 50 pays différents.
Chaque jour, des centaines
de nouvelles personnes nous rejoignent.
Nous visions de réaliser
une entreprise à mission,
nous avons finalement créé
la première entreprise à but non lucratif
dédiée au climat.
Les bénéfices ne sont pas
calculés en euros,
mais en tonnes de gaz à effet
de serre évitées ou captées.
Nous croyons en l'intelligence collective.
En un an,
nous avons étudié collectivement
plus de 500 solutions
pour lutter contre les gaz
à effet de serre.
5 000 personnes
jouent le rôle d’évaluatrices
et d’évaluateurs de ces solutions.
Ensemble, ce collectif a détecté
les 20 solutions les plus pertinentes
pour résoudre ce problème.
Depuis, un comité scientifique
de 14 experts
a validé la pertinence de ces innovations.
Collectivement, nous avons également
rassemblé plus de six millions d’euros.
Six millions d’euros
qui nous permettent aujourd’hui
de financer les trois
meilleures solutions,
les trois premières
de Time for the Planet.
Sur ces trois premières solutions,
nous avons détecté trois talents,
des entrepreneurs, des profils
du monde de l’action,
qui viennent compléter les équipes
scientifiques porteuses de ces solutions.
Et ces trois solutions vont être
partagées gratuitement
en licence libre, afin de pouvoir
être copiées, améliorées
et commercialisées partout dans le monde.
Ce projet un peu fou est lancé,
mais finalement,
est-ce qu’il est si fou que ça ?
Face au changement climatique,
la folie, c’est de continuer
de se comporter de la même manière
et d’espérer des résultats différents.
Alors non, ne soyons pas fous,
innovons !
Merci.
(Applaudissements)